that's why we bring in fox news
contributor tom holman former acting
director of vice i think i was a little
stunned actually looking at the qr code
tom the administration has said that
they have made it very clear to the
migrants saying do not come but they are
so organized i don't even know how to
make a qr code
and they've got they've got this thing
all right that's how you sign up to get
get a board
the bottom line is look
we got the first president in history
this nation
that came into office within days
intentionally unsecured the most secure
border we ever had dana i mean under
president trump we had illegal
immigration down 80 81
most secured border in my entire career
35 years most secure board in my
lifetime and we have a president that
came in within days unsecured the border
and we got a secretary of homeland
security that's helping him do that it's
it's it's unbelievable what they have
done and when you unsecure the border
that's when
there's no downside of securing the
board it's less drugs less illegal
immigration less millions made by the
cartels less women sexually assaulted
less women dying less opioids coming in
this country that you know they killed
92 000 over adult deaths this year he
intentionally unsecured the border that
is the most unpresidential thing i've
ever heard him and the secretary should
both be impeached if you look at the
video the mexican government is
assisting these caravans to get to the
u.s border under president trump mexican
government had military on the southern
border military on the northern border
they helped to secure the border matter
of fact the mexican government helped
more to secure the border than the
democratic-led congress did and this has
been a complete 180 turnaround and it's
it's by design it's not incompetence
it's not mismanagement this is what they
want and this is why they haven't done
one thing not one thing to slow the flow
why would this be by design what what
would be the ultimate intent
by the way you've got the judge's order
to remain in mexico to go into action in
november we assume it will take place
that was one of the big tools you used
uh to keep migrants on the southern side
of the border go ahead and explain
yourself
i i the president sold out to the
progressive left and win the election
and now he's keeping his promise and
look they they truly believe in their
hearts these are future democratic
voters they don't have to vote all they
got to do is be counted in the next
census because president biden also
overturned trump census rule so these
are they think this is going to lead to
perpetual power in congress it's going
to lead to you know them being
empowering congress for years to come
that's the only reason you'd want to
unsecure border nobody wants more drugs
more illegal immigration cartels making
millions women being sexually assaulted
people dying under president trump he
actually the wall and everything he's
done if immigration is down 83
how many lives were saved how many
millions did the cartels make how many
children didn't die i have a thought too
which is that apparently the democrats
are trying to get their reconciliation
bill done and there are reports that
they might try to add the immigration
reform or including amnesty into that
bill to get it done that doesn't really
send the signal to migrants that they
shouldn't come to the border
no everything they're doing the
secretary last week he sent a memo to
ice basically saying
being in the country illegally is no
longer enough to make an arrest he said
that it's not worth the word he did a
paragraph in there that being illegally
in the united states is no longer
illegal there's not a reason to arrest
an illegal alien anymore they have to be
convicted of a serious crime that sends
the message when he got congress talking
about passing amnesty that sends a
message when you when you stop building
the wall that sends a message this
administration every step they've taken
sends a wrong message and they wonder
why the numbers are increasing look
highest we went the most secure border
to an historic high this past year more
illegal crossings than ever in the
history of this nation and they did that
with nine months so congratulations to
the progressives they're winning the war
on this
tom holman thank you sir for coming in
today um
it's not going away we'll see in a
couple weeks okay i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now